pudiste contratar a todos sean
sanitarios estamos preparando el pollo
ya que es de acuerdo a tu pregunta para
su gestión no ok corazón
garau ok para todos había continuación
romper filas yo pueda tu pelo
descansen
operación comida de ramadán para jóvenes
en abandono escolar o desorientados
y creo que es bueno poder ayudar a la
gente antes de estar en la asociación yo
no hacía nada por los demás y
francamente me aburría siempre quise
ayudar y nunca lo había hecho y esta es
una ocasión de hacerlo
de las cocinas ocho mamás africanas y
cada día un plato distinto
sea el portón de atrás es importante
ayudar a las personas que lo necesitan
el reclamo hasta aquí en el mes sagrado
del ramadán es un privilegio importante
como jefe de maniobra el comandante
abdul hussein un ex oficial de marina
chicos todo lo que aprendan ahora nos
servirá durante 37 días
cuando uno quiere a su equipo hay que
ayudarlos sin dudar y ustedes ven la
calma reina aquí están mar adentro
banalizar las velas y llegaremos
este día misión cumplida cuatrocientos
setenta y dos porciones de comida son
preparadas y distribuidas como en esta
periferia vecina donde la bienvenida es
un poco accidentada y de una donde está
el pequeño allí estoy llegando espero lo
llaman aquí el comandante en jefe
encarga el caudillo local la
distribución de las porciones e intenta
pasar yo lo que quiero y lo digo de
nuevo con fluido el éxito 'agente un
poco hay que construir ciudadanía la
república en calma
un desafío ambicioso renovado cada día
durante un mes